bonjour à toutes les sources on est en
direct sur brut avec fabrice arfi co
responsable du pôle enquêtes de
mediapart on va à revenir sur la sphère
de rugy toutes les révélations qui ont
lu ces derniers jours avec fabrice arfi
pourquoi parce que tout simplement c'est
le journaliste qui a révélé toutes ces
informations que vous avez pu voir dans
la presse on va revenir
point par point sur les informations
avec lui et également en réponse avec
cette interview de françois de rugy qui
a lieu ce matin chez nos confrères de
rmc
bonjour fabrice arfi merci de nous
accorder du temps sur brut on vous
imagine assez sollicités ces derniers
jours
dans un premier temps j'ai envie qu'on
revienne sur les différents points de
révélations qui ont commencé cette
semaine
voilà je vous laisse peut-être expliquer
peut-être un peu déroulés les faits dans
un premier temps les révélations ça se
passe autour de l'assemblée nationale et
des dîners oui ça peut ressembler à une
sorte de série netflix journalisme avec
les premières révélations c'est est ce
qu'on a appelé la vie de château du
couple du rgi quand françois de rugy qui
l'actuel numéro deux du gouvernement
qu'elle seule d'ailleurs qu'à nos
statuts du ministre d'état ministre de
l'ecologie
logis quand il était président de
l'assemblée nationale avec son épouse
ils ont organisé entre octobre 2017 et
juin 2018
une bonne grosse dizaine de dîners entre
amis entre copains des agapes financé
sur fonds publics qui était digne des
grandes idées d'état avec les plus beaux
crus classés de la cave de l'assemblée
nationale des bouteilles qui écoutait
parfois à 500 ou 600 euros la bouteille
jamais des bouteilles à moins de 100
euros la fameuse photo qui a maintenant
fait le tour du monde puisqu'il ya des
bornes d'arcade fire fine des homards la
mobilisation du personnel de l'assemblée
nationale c'est à dire rémunérées par le
contribuable
les cuisiniers les serveurs livrés pour
des dîners dont il est difficile de
trouver un lien évident avec la fonction
de président de l'époque d'ailleurs
séverine de re j elle même reconnaît que
c'était un cercle amical et que c'était
elle qui faisait son exposition un film
up relationnel dans l'indication des
convives et plusieurs des participants
je peux penser à jean neige à la bâtie
par exemple qui a été présent un soir et
qui a dit si c'était à faire je me
referais je ne referai pas et qui a
reconnu que c'était pas des dîners de
travail d'ailleurs il se retrouvait là
pourquoi parce que sa femme est une très
bonne amie de séverine de rufisque
évidemment
en droit le plus absolu même ça ce
seront les premières révélations des
fonds publics pour des idées dont il est
difficile de trouver un lien avec la
fonction de président j'ajoute juste que
françois de rugy lui même à cette
expression étrange pour qualifier ces
dîners il parle de réunions de travail
informel donc on voit bien l'espace
d'anti phrase qui fait lui-même pour
qualifier cette bizarrerie qui a choqué
l'opinion publique et fonctionne en
régie lui-même reconnaît que le client
et digitimes manchots qui deuxième
révélation c'est les travaux les travaux
non là on parlait de la santé lundi à
l'assemblée nationale c'est vrai
qu'ensuite il a été nommé ministre de la
transition à l'écologie et en 2010 - la
likouala hulot démissionne démissionne
chez nos confrères de france inter
une annonce et c'est françois de rugy
qui est nommé ministre d'état et en
émergeant du gouverment érosion du
gouvernement british et l'écologie et il
quitte la présidence de l'assemblée
nationale il devient ministre d'état et
il profite d'un logement de fonction un
grand appartement dans un hôtel
particulier au ministère de l'écologie
ce qui est normal qu'il y ait des
logements de fonction et sitôt arrivé il
ya des travaux qui sont engagés dans les
appartements privés du ministre pour
quand même 63000 euros de travaux
financés par l'argent public donc pareil
comme les dîners sur les impôts des
contribuables et parmi ces travaux qui
peuvent paraître extravagant il ya par
exemple un dressing à 17000 euros
ce soi disant il n'y avait pas de plat
car il y avait pas d'armoire m'a dit
de rugy il ya des peintures pour plus de
30000 euros
et pour justifier de ces travaux qui
sont en réalité des travaux de confort
comme le disait compris les
entrepreneurs qui ont été sollicités
ouais on parle de la vétusté le
ministère parle de la vétusté de
l'appartement maintenant on a publié les
photos ça que vous avez publié plusieurs
formats doc et des photos enfin
plusieurs personnes parlent d'un petit
peu plus fort d'ailleurs très peu on a
publié plusieurs photos du dit
appartement avant travaux
on voit bien qu'ils ont qu une vétusté a
contrario le ministère pour justifier de
ladite vétusté nous a envoyé trois
photos un tapis déchirer une tache sur
une moquette est un petit bout de mur
salies en ayant recadré une photo où il
se trouve qu'on a obtenu la faute
originelle où on voit qu'il ya un très
bon état général
et quand vous quelque part c'est la
manipulation en terme d'image noble et
c'est à dire qu'on essaye de démontrer
la virtus et d'indiens qui n'est pas
vétuste donc ce sont des travaux de
confort financés par l'argent du
contribuable par nous mêmes parce qu'ils
s'acquittent de l'impôt
je rappelle les chiffres un dressing à
17000 euros
et évidemment que ça ne peut que en
crise économique mouvement des gilet
jaune baisse des apl sunnites et
d'indignation pas seulement des citoyens
mais également en fait des certains
pontes de la république en marge le
secrétaire d'état gabriela talent ce
matin au micro de france inter disait
qu'il était choqué
benjamin griveaux aussi sur france 2 les
germains griveaux a déclaré que ça à
renvoyer une image terrible que françois
de rugy renvoyer une image terrible de
la politique donc le l'intérêt public et
la légitimité de ce que nous révélons je
crois ne ne fait pas débat
troisième élément de révélations ça
concerne la directrice de cabinet de
françois de rugy
nous avons révélé que cette préfète de
formation qui a une carrière absolument
impeccable qui est réputé d'ailleurs
pour être une autre fonctionnaire
admirable en dépit de cela a profité
pendant 17 ans d'un logement social et
même pendant 12 ans alors qu'elle n'y
habitait plus calé à qu'elle était en
fonctions d'ailleurs à plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de paris
alors là françois de rugy a été
intraitable avec un coeur en une heure
il a viré il a limogé sa directrice de
cabinet à vous fait ces révélations je
crois mercredi soir est donc dans la mli
dans la soirée l on apprend je veux
c'est vers 00h30 un convoi sur elle et
limogés à la demande du ministre qui est
intraitable avec elle qu'il est un peu
moins avec lui même et le lendemain nous
avons révélé que ce même ministre
profite depuis 2016 alors qu'il est
vice-président de l'assemblée nationale
à l'époque c'est à dire que l'un des
élus les mieux rémunérés de la
république d'un logement qui a une
vocation sociale
c'est pas un logement à proprement
parler social sa part un bailleur social
mais qui invoque une vocation sociale
parce qu'il appartient à un régime un
dispositif qui s'appelle le scellier
social intermédiaire c'est-à-dire que
des propriétaires font des
investissements des travaux dans un dans
un appartement en contrepartie de quoi
et de défiscalisation il faut accueillir
des revenus modestes à l'époque où il
entre dans l'appartement
monsieur nos logis et vice président de
l'assemblée nationale il n'a pas
d'enfant à charge il vient de se séparer
ça c'est sa vie privée c'est pour ça
qu'il est moins cher un appartement
il est tout sauf un revenu modeste à
partir de juin 2010 est il à des
logements fonctions et à l'assemblée
nationale et au ministère de l'écologie
où il passe tout son temps donc il
appartement près de nantes n'est pas une
résidence principale et bras donc c'est
ce que nous révélons est aujourd'hui la
défense de monsieur de rugy c'est à dire
en fait on n'a pas informé
je ne savais moi il y avait cette
vocation sociale derrière ça
c'est un peu une sorte de richard
virenque des privilèges dans tous ses
volets là monsieur d'origine puisque le
vin en fait il dit qu'il aime pas c'est
pas lui qui choisit c'est pas les
homards il est allergique au constat des
pour l'appartement et le dressing à
17000 euros c'est pas lui c'est le
ministère et puis pour le logement il a
même été carrément victime d'une sorte
de complot ou d'une tricherie c'est son
mot de la part de la propriétaire et 2
agence immobilière voilà nous ce sont
les faits que nous révélons les éléments
de langage
alors voilà le récapitulatif des faits
on va l'occasion de reprendre point par
point également avec les arguments que
françois de rugy a donné ce matin chez
nos confrères de rmc
l'occasion de saluer toutes les
personnes qui regardent pour cela
n'hésitez pas à commenter à poser vos
questions dans les commentaires à
partager ce direct aussi avec vos amis
voilà plus on est nombreux mieux c'est
toujours cette première question là tout
simplement
françois de rugy ce matin il a il
envisage tout simplement de porter
plainte pour dénonciation calomnieuse
envers mediapart
votre première réaction sur des
réactions c'est qu'en tant que citoyen
je suis extrêmement assuré qu'ils ne
soient pas ministre de la justice et qui
soit ministre de l'écologie parce que
juridiquement ça ne veut absolument rien
dire même pire que ça c'est une
absurdité ce qu'ils racontent les
plaintes éventuelles qu'on pourrait
déposée contre mediapart ce qui a
évidemment son endroit et nous avons à
répondre devant de nos écrits devant la
loi je n'ai aucune inquiétude vis-à-vis
de ça c'est pour la diffamation mais pas
la dénonciation calomnieuse la
dénonciation calomnieuse désolé pour
ceux qui nous regardent je veux faire un
tout petit peu de bois et un peu de
précision n'est pas inutile dans ce
débat il ya d'un côté la communication
et de l'autre l'information la
dénonciation calomnieuse un délit qu'on
peut reprocher à quelqu'un qui va saisir
l'autorité policière ou judiciaire d'un
éventuel délit en sachant qu'il est faux
donc nous avons saisi aucune autorité
policière ou judiciaire
nous n'avons pas parlé de telli
sympa magistrats dont on n'est pas là
pour qualifiés pénalement ce que nous
racontons événements des informations
d'intérêt public et vérifiées et ça
n'est pas faux puisque monsieur
d'origine ou conteste aucune véracité de
nos informations concrètement un il dit
il ya des mensonges dans les papiers il
dit jamais lesquels est à ce point qui
ne les dément pas qui le reconnaît la
légitimité de votre travail puisqu'il
reconnaît la légitimité de l'indignation
que cela suscite voilà ma réaction c'est
que monsieur bourgi se défend comme il
veut y compris en racontant
juridiquement absolument n'importe quoi
alors contrôler un point juridique
françois de rugy ce matin dit vous avez
déjà vu un article de mediapart ou ou le
résultat du procès où leur information
aura été infirmée par la justice ça va
vous aurais répondu juste le monde mais
ça n'a aucun sens en fait on ne juge pas
la qualité du journalisme à l'aune de la
décision judiciaire mais là ce le
journalisme il est là pour produire des
faits vérifiés dans tes république
parfois il ya des qualifications pénales
parfois il y en a pas donc messi mais je
peux répondre à monsieur de rugir de
parler de jérôme cahuzac
je compte live d'alk il a été condamné
soucieux mais lequel il a été condamné
certains soient mises en examen d'autres
s'en sortent mais ça ne me fait pas
retirer une seule ligne de ce coût de ce
que nous écrivons précisément ceux qui
nous reprochent d'être des procureurs
parce que nous sommes pas nous sommes
des journalistes nous reproche que la
conséquence de nos articles ne soient
pas des condamnations pénales parfois
voyez la situation absurde dans laquelle
se retrouvent ceux qui sont les vraies
personnes qui alimente le poujadisme
ce sont ces comportements là qui
alimente le poujadisme et le populisme
c'est quand on s'attaque à la presse qui
fait son métier c'est quand on voit des
bouteilles de vin à 600 euros le litre
et des homards géants dont je doute
d'ailleurs qui viennent de bretagne je
ne sais pas vraiment des vaucrises in de
l'assemblée nationale c'est cela qui
alimente le populisme c'est qu'en face à
ça c'est
evènement pardon la première réaction
c'est de dire j'assume et j'assume tout
sur un mode circulez ya rien à voir
alors que le lendemain on reconnaît que
c'est normal que l'opinion soit choqué
et que sur l'ensemble on va dire je vais
rembourser tous des heureux contester
les amis d'hier que s'il est prêt à
rembourser des heureux contestées il
reconnaît qu'il a eu une utilisation
privée dé l'argent public enfin et c
c'est extravagant donc c'est comme ça
que ça va se passer maintenant c'est à
dire que quand on fait une faute quand
quelqu'un imaginez qu'on traduit ça dans
la vie commune un voleur il vole quelque
chose et puis il va dire ben non mais si
je le ramène c'est bon je ne dis pas que
monsieur d'origine
un voleur mais vous voyez bien la
logique intellectuelle qui a qui sous
tend ce type de réaction je comprends
qu'ils aient une émotion dans le pays
que monsieur de rhji soient accueillis
par des homards géants en plastique dans
ses déplacements mais qui est surtout un
immense embarras et malaise au sein même
de la majorité le président stack alors
au niveau des différents points j'ai dit
qu'on allait reprendre point par point
ses arguments reprenons le début de vos
révélations vous évoquez justement ces
dîners à l'assemblée nationale le
premier point qu'il évoque ce matin
c'est de dire moi je ne ne connaissaient
pas le prix de ces bouteilles s'est
servi par le personnel de l'assemblée ce
que c'est vraisemblable non c'est pas
vrai ce temps là pour une simple et
bonne raison c'est que le personnel de
l'assemblée c'est les maîtres d'hôtel et
les serveurs ont livré son vernis les
fonctionnaires les plus capés les plus
responsables et plus conscients à foix
de ski et l'éthique publique
et vous pensez sincèrement que le
responsable de la cave de l'assemblée où
les sommeliers ils sortent des crues à
600 euros la bouteille pour les dîners
entre copains et entre amis
du président et sa femme sentier des
autorisations ils ont dû par exemple un
mouton rothschild de 2004 qui était un
mouton rothschild qui avaient été
produits pour les 100 ans de l'entente
cordiale entre l'angleterre et la france
fait partie du patrimoine ces choses là
donc la réponse de monsieur du rugby et
extravagante il nous dit moi je connais
pas le vin j'aime pas le vin mais enfin
on fait pas des révélations sur son
régime alimentaire il dit les homards
moi j'en mange pas je suis allergique
aux crustacés mais enfin c'est pas la
question
la question c'est celle du mélange des
genres entre des dîners la récurrents
avec entre 10 et 30 convives à chaque
dîner qui sont financés avec l'argent du
contribuable et le mélange des genres
entre eux ce qui relève de la vie privée
ou en tout cas difficilement d'un lien
avec la fonction du président de la
république et du président de
l'assemblée nationale par monts et les
fronts et les fonds publics c'est ça la
question
personne ne remet en cause et sûrement
pas mediapart le fait qu'il puisse y
avoir de la pas rares dans la république
qui puisse y avoir des dîners financé
par l'argent public on puisse voir des
bonnes bouteilles c'est bien sûr c'est
pas la question mais ça c'est pour les
dîners entre chefs d'état avec les
parlementaires avec vous rendez compte
que ces dîners sont organisés entre amis
ce que confirme séverine de rougir je
peux pas faire mieux mon père que gégé
séverine de logis au téléphone lundi
matin j'ai vingt minutes d'entretien
enregistré avec elle elle dit oui c'est
un cercle amical avant les révélations
en avant les relations une source
confronte à tout le temps les gens avant
elle me dit oui c'est notre cercle
amical
alors bien sûr il peut y avoir par
capillarité des personnes rapporté oui
jo perd un filtre relationnel dans les
listes d'invitation mais sa défense qui
est une acrobatie que je recommande à
personne le
chez soi c'est de dire à partir du
moment où c'est dans un lieu public
l'assemblée nationale ça n'est pas privé
savons rien mais c'est ça sa ligne de
défense à madame du rgi monsieur aphatie
est l'un des participants dit que
c'était tout sauf du travail
on est donc je ne comprends même pas
qu'on discute en fait véritablement
autour de la nature de sites parce que
françois de rugy ce matin lui parle de
dîners thématiques et ballets alors par
exemple moi j'ai un plan table d'un des
dîners la forme expliquer le caractère
thématique là un journaliste qui n'a
rien à voir par exemple avec le
producteur de cinéma qui à côté
une personne qui a été un ancien patron
de boîte de nuit quelqu'un qui est dans
la finance monsieur de rugy sa femme
voilà mais si ces thématiques peut-être
qu'il ya des comptes rendus peut-être
que si ces thématiques peut-être que le
cabinet a réfléchi à tout ça
donc il ya peut-être des mecs avec sur
quoi on va travailler quel thème on va
ils sont incapables de produire le
moindre élément matériel
donc je bondis ils se défendent comme
ils veulent mais ils vont même jusqu'à
dire le couple du rgi que c'est dîner
était organisé pour que françois durr
giresse connecté à la société qui
restent connectés aux vrais gens
le conseil qu'on est connecté avec des
bouteilles à 600 euros avec les homards
géants avec tout ce que la république
peut offrir grâce aux impôts pour se
goberger à quelques-uns voilà donc
encore une fois ils disent ce qu'ils
veulent
moi je ne réponds que de ce que j'écris
et des éléments y compris matériel que
nous que nous publions d'où les photos
les photos et les publient pas pour
faire le buzz ou à les publier pour
montrer la réalité c'est une sorte de
d'obscénité d'obscénité au sens
étymologique du terme l'obs elle sait ce
qui est hors la scène obscène or la
scène est bien ce que nous montrons par
ses photos ses skis et or la scène et
c'est à ce point problématique pour
monsieur du rgi je le redis il a inventé
cette formule
incroyable
deux dîners professionnels informel
alors il ya madame qu'ils disent et le
cercle amical il ya monsieur qui dit
c'est informel et on va nous faire
croire que c'est un en lien direct avec
la fonction de président d'international
chacun jugera françois berger lui parle
de trois photos volées sortis de leur
contexte
non elles ne sont pas sortis de leur
contexte elles sont en plein dans le
contexte et c'est marrant parler de
photos volées si on on revendique le
fait que c'est un lien avec le les
attributions publique du président de
l'assemblée nationale il faut savoir ce
que c'est des photos floues et où voilà
non c'est des photos évidemment
d'intérêt public nous violons la vie
privée de personnes
c'est à dire que toutes les personnes
concernées sont contactés dans les
articles monsieur de rugy contacter
avant à chaque fois madame séverine rue
j ai contacté avant à chaque fois le
cabinet du ministre enfin voilà donc on
respecte les calmants déontologie le
mieux être de notre profession non c'est
pas sorti de son contexte mais
l'occasion d'y revenir justement sur la
limite la série d'origine
elle pose devant la fameuse bouteille de
mouton rothschild 2004 moi si j'ai pu
identifier la dizaine de grands crus
c'est j'ai pas tout vu mais si j'ai pu
l'identifier c'est pour deux raisons
c'est parce que les bouteilles on les
voit sur les photos donc engouement on
peut analyser des étiquettes et puis
retrouver les prix comme ça qu'on voit
que c'est décrit parfois certaines des
bouteilles se vendent aujourd'hui à 1000
1200 euros la bouteille
et puis par ailleurs parce que j'ai les
cartons d'invitation de céline et j'ai
la copier des cartons d'invitation il ya
les vins qui sont dotés voilà il n'y a
pas marqué par contre le thème de la
soirée un patron très remarqué la
nourriture et les mains et vous évoquez
justement la liste des invités en dix
ans il y avait un jeune gitan
producteurs du cinéma et ses terres est
ce que ces listes des invités
vous avez les révéler un moment donné
ces spécialités je pense que vu la la
position on va dire la posture de
monsieur et madame
rhji face à ça je pense que oui au bout
d'un moment une fois qu'on aura contacté
tout le monde on va on va raconter un
peu les invités je vous ai dit mais
encore une fois donc le travail du jeune
et ses nombreuses l'avait fait marrer à
cette histoire c'est quand je vois
certains journalistes
et pour le coup je mets vraiment jean
michel aphatie de côté alors que on a eu
parfois tous les deux maille à partir
notamment - d'affaires cahuzac mais je
dois lui reconnaître une totale
sincérité dans sa façon de répondre
quand on l'a contacté il dit chose
oui je suis allé là bas je ne vais
jamais à dîner mais j'y suis allé parce
que ma femme est ami avec séverine
d'origine c'est elle qui m'invitent
c'est bien la preuve que c'est par le
cercle amical et je n'aurais pas dû y
aller parce que c'était pas
professionnel et je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait aucun sens à ce que je
sois là mais quand j'entends maintenant
douze journalistes qu'on peut être n'ont
peur que leurs noms sortent dans la
presse
raconter que abba with an participé au
dîner mais y'a pas de quoi fouetter un
homard comme je n'ai lu dans le nouvel
obs pour aller contre l'indécence de
tout ça j'en fait c'étaient surtout des
dîners qui était ennuyeuse landais
compte que ça renvoie de l'image de la
profession de journaliste qui va dans
les palais de la république de siphonner
les caves pour des dîners qui sont
informelles avec des amis du président
de l'assemblée nationale et de sa femme
moi je sais que je trouve ça sidérant ce
que ça renvoie d'eux
de l'image parfois deux je déteste
l'essentialisation et de voilà d'une
france d'en-haut quoi les nuls france
d'en haut qui fait ça en se justifiant
de pour rester connecté à la france d'en
bas
aujourd'hui vous discutez avec fameuse
j'imagine que vous avez pris contact
avec différents invités ce que vous avez
sur ses listes sans forcément rêver
leurs noms parce que j'imagine que vous
ferez sur mediapart mais cette c'est
quoi un peu le contenu ce qu'alain
certains qui sont des nids ou d'autres
comme quand la voiture de jean michel
aphatie site mais maintenant il ya plein
de gens qui sont sincères être des gens
n'ont pas forcément envie de sortir
publiquement qu'ils racontent
c'était des trucs en prime c'était débat
n'a alors après un ami peut amener
quelqu'un d'intéressant mais je lis
parfois la presse il ya des amis du
couple kidiaba voilà on a parlé
politique on a parlé de mon métier et
oui mais moi aussi quand je fais des
dîners entre potes
en fait je parle de politique et du
boulot de les copains ou du mien c'est
pas c'est pas la question
là la question c'est que c'est un filtre
relationnel amical madame de rugy je le
redis je le répète le confirme elle même
pour des dîners où il ya des dépenses
importantes et on voit maintenant qu'il
ya même eu deux journalistes je pense
par exemple au parisien qui a révélé
l'utilisation de fonds publics pour des
dépenses personnelles le couple du rgi
on parle beaucoup du fameux ses cheveux
à la feuille d'or à 500 euros par
exemple alors lui dire voyez pas de ça
n'existe pas non il dit à ses plus
ambigu moi je ne sais pas c'est parisien
ce qu'il faut demander aux parisiens
mais il dit c'est françois de rugy à une
stratégie de communication que je
connais bien et puis j'ai en tant que
journaliste qui consiste à démentir ce
qui n'a jamais été dit c'est que la
meilleure façon d'avoir raison il dit un
sèche cheveux plaqués or on sait pas ce
qui a été écrit si on peut rentrer dans
le détail gens avec le parisien parle
d'un sèche-cheveux dyson à 3,99 euros là
avec des feuilles d'or il ne dément pas
le prix une dément pas sont inexistants
il dit qu'il ya un sèche-cheveux qui est
même resté à l'assemblée nationale
mais il y a
plaqué or comme s'il dément je crois pas
que ce soit ce que les confrères du
parisien écrit mais moi je bonbons
quelque part il démonte quelque chose et
n'aimant rien et ils dépendent il parle
d'autre chose essentielle et pas vers
donc c'est essayer c'est une stratégie
de communication on a vu un françois de
rugy ce matin très qu'elle semblait
assez affecté même parfois même au bord
des larmes
justement vous évoquez sa communication
quand vous l'avez ressenti vous qui
connaissez peut-être un peu le
personnage depuis les bras mais moi je
suis toujours un peu gêné parce que
comment dire et c'est contrairement à ce
qu'ils pensent en tout cas ce qu'il dit
il ya rien à dominer mladin faut quand
même savoir que françois de rugy le
premier jour a dit que je m'attaquais
entre guinée ces mots qu'il utilise à
lui parce qu'il a un nom à particule
il a quand même 10 1 comme s'il y avait
une particule aux phobies chez moi tout
le monde sait que j'ai fait des
révélations sur nicolas de sarkozy
alexandre 2b mana jérôme deux cas les
usa compatriotes de balkany et c'est
précisément pour ça que je les avais
titiller dans mes dents mais dans mes
enquêtes
tout ça n'a évidemment pas de sens de
dire quand on en est à ce point à
remettre en cause le messager pour faire
diversion vis-à-vis du message voilà on
va pas me faire sourire je vois pas bien
ce que je peux répondre de sens et à ça
ils nous traitent quand même de coupeur
de têtes ou d'acharnement mais moi
l'occasion du mois de juin les
chargements que je vois c'est celui de
monsieur d'origine son épouse qu'ils
aient les fonds publics de manière à ce
que ça pose des questions au sein de
l'opinion par exemple lui il parlera
donc de vos titres en 10 ans elle a vite
château on attaque parce que mon nom de
rugy lui c'est un peu l'un de ses
arguments il a répondu ça non c'est
plutôt parce que
on a des principes du nouveau monde qui
font parfois penser à l'ancien régime
voilà l'ancien régime sont fastes le
mélange des genres entre le privé et
public avec les impôts quand on demande
aux français de faire des efforts
quand on réduit les apl quand il ya pas
d'argent dans les hôpitaux qui est sûre
gentil se multiplient les semaines de
grève que les gens n'en peuvent plus
n'ont pas les moyens de subvenir à leurs
besoins
oui ce vite château renvoie non pas à la
particule de monsieur dur j'y mets à un
espèce de parfums d'ancien régime en
cédant ces pratiques si c'était appelé
françois de rugy
j'aurais titre et la vie de château
pareil voilà ça m'a absolument mais
aucun sens de d'en être à ce point là
dans le niveau d'argumentation
alors vous évoquez cette citation parce
que c'est vrai que ce matin il était et
vous vous chargez on va dire il a parlé
vision de coupeur de têtes en parlant de
bons parlant de médiapart
qu'est-ce que ça suscite un peu comme
réaction quand vous entendez ça mais
recule c'est moi je ça me suis cite
aucune réaction si ce n'est une forme de
mépris pour cette communication et en
même temps il communique comme il veut
je veux dire chacun fait comme il veut
maintenant je le vois affecté au bord
des larmes ça me fait pas plaisir je
dire si j'ai pas de plaisir
professionnel à sa aucunement j'ai tout
à fait conscience et je veux tout à fait
bien croire que c'est extrêmement
désagréable pour lui et pour madame de
rugy ce que nous racontons je veux dire
je la pâte humaine dans tout ça je dis
conscience de ça évidemment mais ça va
pas m'empêcher de faire mon travail ça
va pas de nous empêcher de faire mon
travail parce qu'il ya pas que mediapart
c'est un collectif et papiers sont pour
la plupart cosigné enfin voilà donc nous
on fait notre boulot coupeurs de tête
mais parce qu'il veut renvoyer à cette
image robespierristes torquemada
procureur qui est une image alimentées
par ceux qui ne nous lis pas je veux
dire c'est pas notre propos nous on est
journaliste et je vois pas comment il
peut tenir
d'un seul point de vue de la
communication de tels arguments quand
lui même reconnaît que les français sont
légitimement choqués par nos révélations
quant lui même reconnaît qu'il est prêt
à rembourser chaque euro contestées
voyez donc c'est incohérent
il est incohérent dans sa non seulement
sa défense près aussi là on parle des
journalistes en général il va dire voilà
enfin et précisément sur votre médecin
il va dire le but c'est d'un franc est
ce que c'est le but c'est d'informer le
public ou de mener des campagnes contre
ceux qui gouvernent
quelque part on a vu au travers ses
différentes déclarations qui vous
accusent presse de militantisme au lieu
d'être journaliste qu'est-ce que j'en ai
mais non non ils nous accusent pas du
tout militantisme pas ce qu'il dit quel
que soit le gouvernement durant le point
presse où il avait le point presse aussi
il a dit quand on fait donc voilà il est
allié à un parti-pris méditant ce qu'on
en fait l'ensemble était rationnée dans
les hameaux politique le militantisme
d'un journal c'est quand il s'attaque à
eux par contre monsieur d'origine vous
adorez avant avec un traîneau papier les
gens vont retrouver sur leur kindle
pause et puis il ya aussi guillaume
daudin de l afp sur twitter qui a
retrouvé tous les tweets et les
déclarations publiques en soutien à
mediapart de françois de rugy
donc en fait en fait quand on faisait
des révélations sur les autres ou sur
ses ennemis politiques qui nous adorent
et ses militants ce à ses militants la
part de monsieur d'origine
1 quand la vérité des faits les
informations profite à son camp
politique qui trouve ça bien
par contre quand ça va ça le concerne
lui il trouve ça mal c'est ça qui est
militant aujourd'hui il ya une dépêche
afp sur mediapart
pourfendeur anticorruption de la droite
et de la gauche ça me va parfaitement
nous on regarde pas la couleur politique
des gens là le
les impôts l'argent public les fonds
publics qui sont mobilisés pour ces
soirées il n'est pas de gauche ou de
droite
la solidarité nationale elle n'est pas
de gauche ou de droite l'argent des
impôts qui servent aux classes au
gendarmerie à la police à l'armée aux
profs il ait pas de gauche ou de droite
les enfants pour mémoire des crèches
publiques
ils sont pas de gauche ou de droite les
bébés bon donc il faut arrêter avec ça
ce sont précisément les zincs politiques
et des femmes politiques qui ont des
carrières militante qui construisent un
parcours sur de l'idéologie qui reproche
à un journalisme qui produit des
informations de faire du militantisme
on marche sur la tête c'est le monde à
l'envers
donc voilà il c'est n'importe quoi pour
faire diversion face à ce qui est la
réalité froide et clinique de
l'information alors on sait que françois
de rugy à cette idée de porter plainte
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure il ya des
propos qui sont quand même si fort jeudi
il justifiait les violences envers les
gilets jaunes ils les soutiennent
quelque part mais est ce que la
politique la nage à me justifier les
violences gilet jaune
jamais jamais jamais c'est quelques le
mouvement des joies des gilets jaunes
soit un mouvement journalistique m'en a
dit est réellement passionnant enfin je
veux dire mais jamais dit le contraire
tout le monde se rappelle notamment du
papier en pâtit de florence aubenas à la
une du monde java tous les journaux tout
le monde s'est occupé de ce mouvement là
et au par contre moi je suis pas pour
l'essentialisation des mouvements je
pense pas qu'il ya que les gilet jaune
c'est un bloc monolithique il ya eu des
choses abject
on a vu des dérives antisémites on a vu
de la violence contre la police
absolument insupportable et scandaleuse
pas plus que je ne fis pour
essentialiser la police pour autant il
ya eu des violences policières inédite
inédite en france des gens qui ont perdu
des mains un oeil
il ya eu deux morts un steve à nantes
la vieille dame octogénaire
de marseille est ce que nous dit le
pouvoir face à cette réalité c'est de
tuer des mots dire on ne veut pas
entendre parler de violences policières
quand on efface les mots comme ça ça a
un seul objectif c'est les faces et la
réalité qui est derrière
un monsieur de logis en nous attaquant
nous il fait pareil
en fait ce qu'il veut c'est en tuant le
message et il veut effacer le message
qu'il ya derrière
je crois que les citoyens qu'ils soient
de droite de gauche ou d'ailleurs peu
importe le public et mes lecteurs je
veux qu'il soit de partout je crois
qu'ils sont un peu plus mature et adulte
que laisse que face à ces attaques vous
comptez répondre d'emploi jeudi sheila
non je suis dedans sinon ma réponse je
dis ça on va pas rentrer nous mêmes dans
le spectacle et l'utilisation de la
justice dont les épaules sont déjà bien
freinent ils ont il ya peu de juge peu
de magistrats beaucoup de dossiers
beaucoup de problèmes on va pas alourdir
la charge de la justice pour un petit
combat picrocholines leur ministre ne
supporte pas nos révélations non
justement d'un point de vue
journalistique c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup de la profession en ce moment
la remise en cause même notamment avec
le mouvement des gille et joli beaucoup
de critiques envers la presse parlons
justement sur la construction d'une
enquête comme celle ci sont bien sûr
entrer dans certains détails qui sont
propres secret des sources
mais à partir de quel moment voilà
est-ce que vous êtes alerté ce que c'est
vous qui avait des éléments comment
c'est très bien combien de combien de
temps dans quel par exemple si on prend
la terre d'origine et c'est très
variable
c'est hyper varia t inquiete on passe
des mois à temps plein et on fait rien
parce qu'on n'y arrive pas parfois on
passe des mois à temps plein et on y
arrive et ont publié par fait des
enquêtes qui dure plus que des mois et
puis parfois ça apprend quelques jours
et là en l'occurrence a duré combien de
là ça a été pas je dis ça se calculerait
pas en semaine mais ça a été
ça a été de très très longues journées
et nuits pendant le travail normes et un
mois et demi d'eau c'est bien mais c'est
très variable parce que il ya l enquête
sur le logement social de la directrice
de cabinet qui en fait avait été
déclenchée avant même que j'aie des
informations sur les dîners fastueux et
les travaux voilà nous candiac le ce que
j'essaie d'expliquer parfois quand je
n'interviens devant des étudiants ou une
des écoles ou à l'université
c'est que ceux qui pensent qu'il ya des
recettes sur les enquêtes que la journée
d'un journaliste denquête même si je
n'aime pas du tout ce terme journalistes
d'information et et archétypale se
trompe en fait une enquête sahamies
l'origine différentes parfois c'est
parce que vous avez un a priori ou
l'esprit un peu mal tourné et donc vous
allez vérifier ça hein et puis si vous
avez vu juste en fait là priori ça
devient une intuition
parfois on se rappelle d'une source il
ya longtemps parfois une source nous
alerte sur le petit bout de la qui
dépasse de la pelote de laine et puis on
des vides tout ça
parfois certains arrivent avec un bout
de documents quelques photos 1 ceux qui
pensent que par exemple la sphère du rgi
c'est quelqu'un qui arrive avec un
dossier de rugy qui à la fois concerne
l'assemblée nationale à la fois les
ministères à la fois son logement à la
fois peut-être d'autres choses que nous
allons révéler qui aurait une sorte de
grand complot derrière mediapart comme y
aurait eu un grand complot derrière le
canard enchaîné pour faire tomber
françois fillon cela ne connaissent rien
à la pratique du journalisme mais je ne
peux pas leur en vouloir
puisqu'on fait parfois trop mal la
pédagogie de ce qu'est notre travail qui
est un travail artisanal et moi et lui
nos sources dans la sphère de rugy elles
sont partout elles sont partout elles
sont dans la fonction publique
elles sont en dehors de la fonction
quelles sont dans des établissements
privés sont dans des entourages elles
sont partout c'est pour ça que nous
avons des informations
et puis pour une enquête par l'enjeu ce
qu'il faut comprendre aussi c'est que
parfois souvent une enquête ce qu'un
chemin qui se fait en marchant
c'est à dire qu'on découvre des choses
au fur et à mesure a fortiori face à un
françois de rugy qui a une telle
communication qui est même par
maintenant très moquer rails et sur les
réseaux sociaux ça veut dire quand on en
est à justifier des agapes sur fonds
publics avec l'argument que je n'aime
pas le vin le champagne me donne mal à
la tête et je suis allergique aux
crustacés
heureusement que les guignols de l'info
n'existe plus la donc dans l'ordre des
révélations serre que c'est vrai que
vous publiez dans un premier temps ce
qui se passe à l'assemblée nationale
mais la première information que vous
avez vous à ma disposition c'est celle
de son logement social à lui non non c d
changement social de la logement social
delà de la directrice de cabinet mais il
ya toujours un delta entre le moment où
on commence une enquête et on a une
information et le moment où on peut la
publier et pour pouvoir publier il faut
avoir respecté le débat contradictoire
pour que les gens comprennent légalement
nous les joueurs et les journalistes
juridiquement en fait on a un code de la
route
on a un code de la route qui est pénales
correctionnelles s'appelle la loi de
1881 de la loi sur la liberté de la
presse
on est sommé de respecter un certain
nombre de critères juridiques
parmi les critères juridiques il ya le
ce qu'on appelle l' enquête sérieuse ce
qu'on met souvent dans le cas de
sérieuses les d'abord on fait pas
simplement des recherches sur google
mais si on respecte le contradictoire le
contradictoire ça veut dire que quand on
écrit sur quelqu'un eh bien on l'appelle
et on lui laisse le temps de réagir pour
pendez son commentaire et son point de
vue avant d'écrire
voilà et donc nous
par exemple la directrice de cabinet
c'est ce qui s'est passé on n'a pas
publié tant qu'on n'avait pas les
réponses définitives de la directrice de
cabinet de monsieur du rgi d'ailleurs
qu'il ya un peu varié dans ses
commentaires entre la première fois on
en a parlé et le moment où elle a fixé
ses commentaires qu'on allait publier
voilà donc voilà c'est un stade c'est un
artisanat qu'on essaye de faire vraiment
le plus sincèrement le plus
méthodiquement à mediapart
c'est pour ça que j'adore ce journal
c'est le collectivement possible un même
si des fois les articles sont signés par
qu'une seule personne n'y a jamais eu
une seule période derrière un article
est un travail collectif
une intelligence journal estime
collective voilà en dessous on ne
s'autorise pas de lui-même sera d
aventure personnelle un article à
mediapart
voilà donc c'est comme ça qu'on essaye
de travailler puis si ça peut participer
au débat public et à des prises de
conscience d'un mois je trouve ça
formidable
alors la réponse de rugy et d'autres
c'est parfois de se dire que c'est une
situation de deux personnes qui veulent
se venger et qui vont les deux les
informations des joints et ce que mon on
arrive à faire la part des choses
quelque part d'éviter est-ce que ce soit
par exemple quelqu'un qui arrive avec
plein de dossiers qui vous dit ah bah
voilà c'est comme ça ça va comme ça
qu'il faut comment on fait comment fait
la part des choses entre quelqu'un c'est
ma main c'est pas de faire la part des
choses de mon point de vue moi je ne
juge pas moralement les sources je dois
savoir d'où elle me parle l'âme humaine
est ainsi faite que souvent parfois
quand quelqu'un parle à un journaliste
c'est parce qu'il a une forme d' intérêt
à le faire
une forme d'intérêts parfois ce n'est
pas le cas parfois c'est des gens qui
sont littéralement habité par une espèce
d'idée
comment ça vous avez des gens
merveilleux dans l'état dans l'appareil
d'état dans les banques partout partout
dans les entreprises qui parfois
prennent des risques eux mêmes pour vous
informer puis parfois il ya des gens ils
le font parce qu'ils ont un intérêt à le
faire
moi je ne bouge pas le nez jamais un mon
métier c'est de raconter le monde tel
qu'il est c'est pas d'être un justicier
ce pas d'envoyer des gens devant un
tribunal c'est de raconter le monde mais
je n'ai pas de meilleure définition du
journalisme consistant à raconter des
histoires vraies et d'intérêt public
points moi j'y viendrai est d'intérêt
public
et ben moi je le fais un honneur dans
mon répertoire dont elle est double
d'avoir des gens de peu des gens de bien
des gens qui ont une moralité au dessous
du niveau de la mer des gens qui ont
fait de la prison
des corrompus et des corrupteurs je peux
pas comprendre ce monde si je parle pas
à ces gens là et par ailleurs c'est pas
parce que des gens font des bêtises on
fait des bêtises ou parfois agissent mal
que ce sont pas des gens intéressants je
veux dire je puisse pas les blocs
monolithiques
moi je suis pour la complexité je suis
pour les zones grises je suis pour rien
et blanc ou noir
donc moi je dois parler à tout le monde
je dois comprendre tout le monde est
dans ce tout le monde les gens ont des
informations parfois les grands menteurs
disent un peu de vérité
il arrive que des paranoïaques et des
ennemis ça veut pas dire que les
menteurs dise la vérité que les parts
elle devient con des ennemis mais voilà
et donc il faut regarder au cas par cas
ce qu une jurisprudence du quotidien le
journalisme et c'est une jurisprudence
du quotidien avec tout le monde
tout le monde donc parfois oui des gens
ont des élans qui sont des élans par
intérêt personnel qui viennent parler à
la presse mois et nous avait dit ah
parceque
faire c est ce que les informations sont
vérifiables et est-ce qu'elles sont
d'intérêt public
si c'est vrai et d'intérêt public c'est
quand même difficile de ne pas les
rendre à qui elles appartiennent aux
citoyens il faut un certain nombre de
sources pour oui bah ouais il ya des
petits adage comme ça dans notre métier
qui dit qu'une source c'est pas toujours
assez vrai que vous pouvez faire un
papier avec une source
un document ça se vérifie enfin voilà et
donc vous savez dans les affaires
libyennes on nous a remis colas sarkozy
l'ancien président nous avait reproché
d'avoir publié un faux document bon ben
ya eu trois démissions trois décisions
de justice un juge d'instruction cour
d'appel de paris cour de cassation qui a
fait litière des accusations de nicolas
sarkozy mme ça a été cinq ou six ans de
bataille judiciaire pour médias pas ça
je vous dirai pas le contraire que quand
on est avec apart
on peut sourire de des réactions
d'urticaire de toute la classe politique
de l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
le concernant mais parfois faut avoir un
peu le cuir épais ça c'est sur un faux
c'est pour ça que on est indépendant que
nous affectons nos bénéfices à la
défense du journalisme voilà parce qu'on
doit défendre notre travail et les
informations que nous que nous publions
alors lorsque vous faites une enquête
justement vous dites vous contacter les
personnes juste avant la publication
demain avant même plusieurs jours
plusieurs jours avant est-ce que parfait
peut y avoir des pressions et c'est de
vous dire bon par exemple est ce que
dans le cas de rugy quand vous contacter
c'est quoi sa première action risquant
de le rue j moi je fais pas ça je lui
avais envoyé un texto lundi matin peu
transparents là dessus lundi matin jean
envoie un texto en même temps à séverine
d'orgies et à françois durr j françois
de rugy par le truchement de son
responsable de la communication me dit
qu'il a besoin d'à peu près 48 heures un
peu plus 36 48 heures pour répondre à
nos origines a rappelé tout de suite
fameuse entrée un entretien à 20 minutes
que j'ai eu mes du sommet seront pas
accordés entre eux et c'était ça qui est
un peu cocasse dans la pratique de
métier c'est qu'au fond madame yeux
rougis pendant cet entretien de 20
minutes enregistrés confirment toutes
vos informations de a à z sur les
travaux mais également et surtout sur
les dîners qu'elle organisée avec les
cercles avec les cercles d'amis monsieur
de rugy nous a envoyé des réponses
écrites longue
il a raison le seuil d'origine quand il
dit qu'il répond à nos questions parfois
on a des administrations ou des
ministères qui disent qu'ils accusent
m'apparaissent même pas réception de nos
questions lui il joue le jeu de la
réponse donc bien sûr on l'enfilé crédit
mais c'est pas parce qu'il répond que
c'est vrai et c'est pas parce qu'il
répond que l'on doit prendre pour argent
comptant ce qu'il dit 1 notre métier
n'est pas dada coup de faire accoucher
la parole de ceux qu'ont déjà la
puissance de la communication avec eux
donc quand ils nous répondent regarde on
vérifie on fait notre travail
donc là pour vous en termes de
communication sont pas accordés c'est un
moment où vous avez les pousses de
françois de rugy
vous n'avez pas tout à fait la même le
même retoqué surprenant d'avoir une
séverine de rugy aussi bavarde et
confirmant de a à z les informations que
nous avions et qui sont au coeur de
l'émotion populaire suite à nos
révélations mais en même temps je trouve
ça je trouve ça presque touchant puisque
la pas succomber aux sirènes de la
communication politique de crise cadres
et des éléments de langage etc
voilà donc elle a donné des
vraiment une version des faits qui
d'ailleurs corroboré en question on
parle d' émotion populaire mais à
travers sa françois de rugy lui répond
il dit bah vous parlez des
représentations des frais de
représentation
mais moi durant ma présence à
l'assemblée nationale ils ont baissé de
13%
c'est d'ailleurs notre article c'était
dans le premier article absolument mais
c'est absurde
on l'a dit bien sûr mais c'est absurde
comme défense parce que ça veut rien
dire donner des pourcentages ce qu'il
faut c'est des valeurs absolues
est ce que ça montre notre histoire
d'ailleurs si lui il est prêt à
rembourser le moindre contestées comme
il m'a dit c'est que peut-être les frais
auraient pu être réduits de bien plus
que 13%
c'est ce n'est pas la question c'est pas
ça s'est fait très bien s'il a réduit de
13 son ensemble mais ça n'enlève rien à
la question de l'intérêt public des
informations concernant les agapes entre
amis payer avec les impôts pour des
dîners dont il est difficile de trouver
un lien avec la fonction de présidente
de l'assemblée nationale digne et qu'il
reconnaît lui-même comme étant informel
voilà donc sa femme reconnaît elle même
que c'est dans le cercle amical sont ses
mots cercle amical bon voilà donc cessé
d artifice de diversion communiqué bouge
c'est vraiment la diversion c'est pas un
argument recevable dire mais voilà ces
500 millions dhs
mais bien sûr je le mets dans la rdc
dans l'article il se vante d'avoir
baissé de 13% mais pour moi avoir le
culot de se vanter d'avoir baissé de 13%
alors qu'on fait ça je trouve que c'est
de mon point de vue j'ai peut-être
l'esprit mal tourné
je trouve que c'est un facteur aggravant
c'est un facteur aggravant c'est à dire
qu'on utilise leur pourcentage pour
calmer le bon peuple alors qu'on sait
très bien qu'on a fait c'est dean est là
et qu'on leur connaît même dans au moins
une moitié du couple de rugy voyez c'est
c'est un facteur aggravant de mon point
de vue de voir un monsieur du rgi
qualité qui a construit son parcours
politique comme le chevalier blanc de
l'assemblée nationale contre la
dilapidation de l'argent public au
parlement et qui fait ça c'est ça qui
fait naître le populisme
c'est ça qui me ces deux là avec le
pouvoir en place nous avons nous avons
un pouvoir qui se présente en dehors de
nos frontières comme le rempart au
populisme et je trouve que les affaires
quand la macro ni pour dire des choses
rapidement il est confronté dévoile chez
chez elle d accès populiste ça a été le
cas avec la ferme et nahla
quelle a été la réaction de la ferme et
nana de monsieur macro face à la flambée
nana c'est ce fameux discours qui
restera dans le quinquennat du président
de la maison de l'amérique latine en
juillet 2018 c'était il ya bientôt un an
discours dans lequel il a mis en cause
la presse le parlement et la justice
c'est ça le populisme c'est le fameux
qu'il vienne me chercher c'est moi qui
suis responsable pénalement qui viennent
me chercher c'est ça le populisme la
presse qui ne cherche plus la vérité
quand on met en cause des
contre-pouvoirs institutionnel
démocratique et citoyen ce pot à ce
point là c'est ça le populisme imaginez
que viktor orban et je compare pas
sorbonne et macro mais imaginez qu'un
viktor orban dont un poutine dit cela on
dirait il me regarde et c'est bien la
preuve que c'est des populistes 1
ce que fait monsieur d'origine le
populisme c'est précisément
l'utilisation est bien plus que des
biens publics et des fonds publics à des
fins potentiellement privé ou entre amis
c'est ce qui alimente le populisme c'est
pas le fait de le révéler un le tous
pourris il ne naît pas de la révélation
des journalistes moi je suis un
combattant acharné du tout secours il
n'y a pas de tous pourris en revanche
qui est ce sentiment vénéneux qui
naissent face à une classe politique
j'ai essentielle ispa la classe
politique face à certains responsables
politiques qui sont incapables de
prendre à bras le corps ces questions de
morale publique d'éthique de bonne
gestion
l'impôt c'est ça qui fait naître la
colère précisément c'est pas les faits
c'est l'absence de réponse républicaine
forte face à ces fléaux savez quand
quand il ya du désordre dans la rue on
dit il faut faire respecter l'ordre
public
mais l'ordre public il met aussi sur ces
questions là on parle de la protection
des sources
on a beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps
notamment avec la tentative de
perquisitions à votre siège ya quelques
mois on avait fait un live dessus que
ceux qui nous regardent pour me voir
juste après il y avait les juristes de
disclose par rapport aux validations des
ventes d'armes au yémen et plus
récemment à rien de chemins qui avaient
été interrogées par la dgs i dans le
cadre de ces révélations sur la sphère
benalla est ce que aujourd'hui en 2019
plus que les autres années la profession
de journaliste de juristes denquête
d'investigation elle est plus en danger
maintenant qu'avant d'avoir moi je
récuse le terme de journée les
investigations
je suis journaliste en fait de
l'information disons que nous avons
assisté en quelques mois seulement sous
la présidence de monsieur macron à une
attaque concertée contre la presse qui
par son ampleur est inédite
factuellement taudis de concerter vous
dit jésus est un moyen vraiment on a eu
le secret des affaires qui a été
utilisée contre des journalistes je
pense aux confrères du monde pour
protéger des informations concernant une
crise sanitaire c'était les implants de
files sur les dispositifs médicaux
ensuite on a eu la loi fait que news qui
est un enfer pavé de bonnes intentions
c'est à dire bien sûr tout le monde veut
lutter contre la fausse information
mais la façon dont c'est fait ça va
pouvoir potentiellement être utilisée
contre non pas une fausse information et
une information qui dérange ensuite on a
eu
le président dans ses déclarations qui
met en cause la presse ne chercherait
plus la mériter antiphrase merveilleuse
d'un président qui en fait tu parles
d'une presse qui révèle les vérités que
les disait qu'il dirige veut précisément
cacher c'est la sphère bennane a
toujours dans la sphère benalla on a ça
a fait le tour du monde
cinq colonnes dans le new york times et
le washington post une tentative de
perquisition excusez du peu par le
parquet de paris et la brigade
criminelle et la brigade criminelle de
mediapart sans base légale dont le seul
objectif et trouver les sources du
journal qui révèle des informations sur
le pouvoir qu'il dérange
ensuite vous l'avez dit l'audition comme
suspect par les services de
renseignements et services de
renseignements intérieurs des confrères
du collectif de journalistes disent
clause qui ont révélé les mensonges du
gouvernement
les mensonges du gouvernement sur la
pire crise humanitaire selon l'onu du
moment à savoir la guerre ou mails
comment la france contrairement à ce que
la ministre des armées contrairement à
ce que le président de la république on
dit répété oui la france vend des armes
à l'arabie saoudite et aux émirats
arabes unis qui servent dans un conflit
qui tuent des milliers de civils 5
millions d'enfants menacés par la famine
et des confrères du disque lowe's dont
les révélations notamment étaient
publiés par mediapart mais aussi par la
radio france ou arte et bien base de
leurs révélations sur un document de la
direction du renseignement militaire que
connaissent et la ministre des armées et
le président de la république c'est à
dire un document de l'intérieur de
l'état
et bien ce qui révèle les mensonges du
gouvernement dans la pire guerre du
moment ce sont eux qui sont comme
suspect par contre comme madame parliez
monsieur macron tout va bien ensuite
nous avons l'audition de ariane chemin
qui avait révélé le premier volet de la
sphère benalla c'est les violences du
1er mai qui à son tour est entendu comme
suspecte avec le président du directoire
du monde louis dreyfus devant la la
j'ai ainsi pour ses écrits dans le monde
n est pas auditionner pour diffamation
je sais quoi elle est auditionnée pour
une compromission d'un secret défense
puis nous avons je continue les
déclarations de cédric au secrétaire
d'état qui a dit qu'il fallait un
conseil de l'ordre
ce que emmanuel macron lui même disait
en 2017
parce que ça venait quand même cette
idée du front national que c était une
idée qu'il n'avait pas croisé depuis
l'italie fasciste des années 30
un an plus tard son secrétaire d'état
propose la même chose
et puis nous avons et s'est vite ravisé
ouais moyennement en finlande il a dit
c'est pas la bonne façon de dire les
chevaux mais peut-être autrement mais il
a dit il faut arrêter qui est des
fausses informations qu'ils fassent
gagner d'autres partis moi je veux bien
qu le 7e que dans sa conception il a 10
et vous les gens qui n'ont rien qu'on
retrouve est il à 10h et maïtena biraben
sur aireth dîner le lendemain ou le
surlendemain c'est vrai que ça fait
beaucoup de polémiques sur les réseaux
sociaux a beaucoup joué mais ça veut
dire que dans sa conception
la presse n'est pas là pour faire perdre
la république en match je crois qu'en
fait nous mais non on n'est pas là pour
faire gagner ou perdre on est là pour
dire les faits un olivier pour dire les
choses et si les choses elles sont
désagréables pour tel ou tel parti
politique il faut qu'il fasse avec parce
que c'est comme ça que ça marche la
démocratie est celui qui l'a peut-être
le mieux disait victor hugo en 1848 il
élu député victor hugo et il dit que la
liberté d'informer et le droit de vote
sont les deux facettes d'une même pièce
en démocratie vous n'avez pas éluder
l'autre vous n'avez pas la démocratie le
droit de vote sont la liberté d'informer
c'est en droit de savoir vous pouvez
voter avec un bandeau sur les yeux
la liberté d'informer sans droit de vote
ça sert à rien de les bourrer de ce qui
se passe il vous pouvez pas décider de
l'avenir de notre nation c'est pas très
dur à comprendre
c'est comme ça que ça se passe et donc
le caractère disruptive de ce pouvoir de
ce2
dupe de ce pouvoir de ce point de vue là
c'est quand même d'oublier un peu
l'histoire et d'où viennent toutes ces
libertés fondamentales je peux continuer
madame mélo mais elle s'est ravisée un
peu plus mais qu'ils voulaient a séché
la loi de 1881 qui est pourtant la loi
qui défend la liberté d'informer avec la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
dans notre pays et qui est une loi de
responsabilisation pénale des
journalistes 1 nous quand on écrit on
peut être poursuivi et condamné
pénalement devant la loi voilà tout ça
mis bout à bout et j'en oublie
c'est une attaque c'est pour ça que je
discutais concertée puisque chaque pan
de l'activité du journaliste et est en
quelque sorte
attaqué pour empêcher de raconter les
faits de la fiction je pourrais rajouter
les violences policières dont certains
journalistes pas que mais certains
journalistes ont été victimes pendant le
mouvement des gilets jaunes dont choses
qu'on a vues sur projet quand même j'ai
quand même chose que vous avez bien sûr
je vois la météo quand j'ai dû avoir
je suivais la manif d'amazon voilà où on
avait quand même une police public qu'il
faut présenter avec mag ont privé je
sais pas comment on appelle ça voilà
donc oui pour répondre à votre question
je trouve qu'on est dans une situation
qui est un peu inquiétante à hiesse côté
lapierre l'autre côté on et non dans
cette année on voit de nombreux sondages
d'opinion à prendre toujours avec des
pincettes mais on voit aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux
de nombreuses critiques envers les
journalistes quelque part c'est quoi la
responsabilité des journalistes bien ce
qui se passera mais l énorme et je vais
pas vous dire qu'on est con et une
profession aimé et moi je ne suis pas
les journalistes
je suis un journaliste par milliards
dans les médias il ya des médias et dans
l'immédiat il ya des journalistes pas
plus que pour ça que j'ai dit que
j'aimais pas bon escient cialis jeu la
classe politique il ya des politiques
voilà qu'il ya un gouvernement qui dans
le gouvernement il ya des ministres
voilà et donc c'est pas interdit d'avoir
des approches à un peu nuancé et
complexe de la réalité est bien sûr que
les journaliers
font partie de l'une des professions les
plus détestés dans ce pays et que
peut-être il ya des bonnes raisons
pourquoi et comment on peut réussir
d'ailleurs je pense que la sphère du rgi
d'incertaines une certaine façon le
montre quant au temps de
d'éditorialistes et de journalistes se
retrouvent dans ces fameux dîner et
aujourd'hui viennent me raconter un peu
tout le monde de but sans mauvais jeu de
mots c'était possible bien que ça y'a
pas de quoi fouetter un homard en
décompte l'image que ça renvoie
vis-à-vis du citoyen et de du lien
incestueux qui peut exister entre le
politique et les journalistes qui sont
censé écrire sur les sur les politiques
mais attention ce que je veux dire c'est
que la critique des médias est
nécessaire mais elle est même
obligatoire dans une démocratie et bien
sûr le fait que l'immense majorité des
médias privés appartiennent à des gens
dont le coeur d'activité des industriels
n'est pas l'information pour l'activité
entre en contradiction parfois avec l'
information libre et indépendante que
ils ont besoin d'être en bonne relation
avec le gouvernement pour avoir des
licences pour vendre des armes avec des
pays étrangers parfois des dictatures
tout ça n'aide pas un écosystème global
pour une information libre et
indépendante pour autant nuance je tiens
avec debout ça ne veut pas dire que dans
ces journaux il ya pas des choses
formidables et ondées le monde il
appartient à xavier niel xavier niel
c'est un copain de macron alors le monde
est vendu à macron un ya des gens qui
racontent des théories comme ça on va le
laisser même le monde qui révèle
l'affairé pénale art et je parle pas de
médiapart ah bon c'est parce qu'on peut
à la fois avoir des actionnaires ils
sont étanches et les lacs et la
situation du monde a dit aux abymes ne
pose pas problème on l'a raconté dans
médiapart
oui pour autant le monde fait un travail
formidable formidable ok c'est pas
interdit de réfléchir de manière
complexe c'est ça que je veux dire mais
attention il ya la critique des médias
mais moi ce que je vois là c'est la
haine du journalisme et ça c'est pas
pareil
un line du journalisme nous avons une
presse qui ne cherche plus la vérité ou
un jean luc mélenchon qui dit que la ld
médias est juste et celle là elle des
médias et justesse elle bon voilà où je
pourrai pas d'autres 1 madame le pen
bond ou un rapport à cette information
qui dérange mais surtout qui les dérange
qui qui dit surtout une haine du fait
démocratique par le journalisme et ça ça
m'inquiète ça ça m'inquiète parce que
parce que ça ça enlève la grammaire
commune aux citoyens pour moi le
journalisme et le journaliste c'est
celui qui participe de cet exercice
quotidien qui consiste à dire que deux
et deux font quatre
1 c'est cette phrase merveilleuse dans
1984 d'orwell avec ce héros la winston
smith qui fait quelque chose de
complètement illégal dans cette dystopie
qui ressemble un régime totalitaire pour
partie inspiré du stalinisme 7 choisi
légal qui fait c'est tenir un journal
intime pas leurs ateliers un journal
il écrit dans son journal intime que le
héros la liberté pour lui c'est la
liberté de dire que deux et deux font
quatre
quand on a ça le reste suivra c'est
merveilleux c'est ça le journalisme
c'est dire que deux et deux font quatre
il consomme email d'accord là dessus
quand on est d'accord sur les faits on
peut discuter quand on est d'accord sur
le fait que le ciel est bleu on peut
discuter on peut ne pas être d'accord
sur l'interprétation sur le climat
rassure la météo sur voila mais on est
en train de perdre en partie à cause de
ceux qui nous représentent pas que bien
sûr qu'il ya des horreurs sur les
réseaux sociaux bien sûr il ya des
horreurs dans la population la
population le peuple n'est pas d'essence
non plus du peuple il ya des citoyens
banc mais quand ceux qui nous
représentent elles sont en eau sont les
premiers producteurs de fausses
informations de fake news d'information
biaisé et de mise en cause du
journalisme alors il écrase la frontière
entre le vrai et le faux
et quand cette frontière est effacé
c'est de là que naissent le pire c'est
une autocritique forte a fait le métier
mais bien sûr qu'on a une immense
autocritique on a des devoir de
transparence sur nos liens d'intérêts
sur la façon dont on travaille mais et
puis qu'on explique ce que c'est le
journalisme vraiment je pense que plein
de gens dans notre pays naïvement
sincèrement ne savent pas on n'est pas
des influenceurs
on n'est pas des valeurs peugeot et
expliquer c'est comment on pourrait les
un journaliste c'est celui qui rend aux
citoyens ce qui lui appartient
une information l'information vraie
d'intérêt public ça appartient aux
citoyens et nous on est là pour raconter
les histoires vraies et d'intérêt public
dans tous les domaines de la cécité pour
que les gens connaissent le monde dans
laquelle est dans le qualifie pour qu'il
connaisse la société dans laquelle ils
vivent pour qu'ils puissent voter en
connaissance de cause de cela on a
reproché au canard enchaîné d'avoir
sorti va faire clients avant l'élection
enfin mon bureau je préfère savoir avant
qu'après je préfère savoir avant de
voter plutôt qu'après d'avoir voté bon
ben voilà ça sert à ça journalisme et de
janvier c'est pas que les affaires c'est
pas que le politico financier mais tout
la santé l'économie la politique
évidemment l'environnement enjeu majeur
au mondial numéro un bon donc voilà et
c'est ça notre boulot c'est un boulot
bizarre parce qu'en fait on ne sait rien
on apprend et on transmet nous avons
fait nos rangs on va aller dans ce qu'on
appelle le journalisme d'investigation
on va chercher en quelque sorte les
secrets d'intérêt public auprès de ceux
qui les cachent pour les rendre à ceux à
qui ils appartiennent les citoyens
quelle que soit leur couleur politique
comment vous vivez sur un peu ce statut
à part on le voit par exemple dans les
commentaires il ya beaucoup de
commentaires qui disent la rva super
mediapart dit mediapart oui qu'ils vont
dire également pareil vis-à-vis du
canard enchaîné on sait que vous êtes
il ya plusieurs médias voient là où
justement il ya des commentaires assez
positif parce que vous pensez qu'elle
est juste est ce que pensait être à part
quelques peurs ou comment nous réjouit
dia pas parce qu'on a par voilà qui est
participatif un jeu
participatif quand vous êtes abonné vous
avez un blog vous pouvez ou l'un de
leurs enseignants puissent nôtres notre
slogan qu'on aime bien la seule nos
lecteurs peuvent vous acheter quoi mais
en même temps moi je me considère pas
comme à parvin vraiment mal mais là je
suis un métier de journaliste que plein
de gens font le plein de rédaction il se
trouve qu'on a créé à mediapart un
écosystème merveilleux c'est un lieu
c'est pas pour faire un employé du moins
je peux m'en fous mais on y est bien
voilà il ya de la camaraderie de
l'intelligence collective on est
indépendant c'est à dire que le journal
appartient à ceux qui le font et à ceux
qui l'ont fondée et en plus on va
renforcer l'indépendance dans les mois
qui viennent pour que le journal a
jamais de soi achetable par notre à
jamais voilà nous on travaille pour la
perpétuité main se protéger du futur et
qu'il n'arrive pas à mediapart dans le
futur ce qui est arrivé au monde et à
libération qui sont des journaux qui
appartenait à ces sociétés de salariés
d'urbanistes et qui ont été récupérées
valin par xavier niel autres par patrick
drahi nous on veut pas que ça nous
arrive ça donc on ne parle de
journalisme et que de ça toute la
journée on a pas de publicité
enfin on a pas d'ingérence extérieure
notre argent c'est que la confiance du
public et on espère qu'on a satisfait on
espère que elle ne cessera de grandir
pas pour verser des dividendes ya pas
gagne des sous mais mediapart n'est pas
un centime de nuit dans un style tout
était à tour et tout est réinvesti dans
la trésorerie pour pouvoir faire face
aux attaques notamment judiciaires
peut-être c'est la passionnée au logis
sera pas la première on en est en train
de 150 et 200 pour
les salariés un pour que socialement ça
se passe bien un salarié et puis pour le
développement notamment techniques et
pourquoi pas faire encore grandir la
rédaction moi je trouve qu'en effet il
ya beaucoup de bienveillance par rapport
à ça et je trouve ça hyper agréable bien
sûr je vais pas dire le contraire mais
que mediapart ou le canard enchaîné
soient vus comme des exceptions
ça dit bien qu'on a un problème ça dit
bien qu'on ait un problème de mon point
de vue on devrait pas dans une
démocratie d exception une percée dans
les commentaires nous interpelle par
rapport à une autre affaire c'est pour
ça je pose la question j'ai
l'interactivité au coeur du live quelque
part au travers certaines questions
c'était des des sensibilités qui
reviennent beaucoup dans les
commentaires mais cette question qui
revient beaucoup par rapport à une
affaire qui fait beaucoup réagir sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est ce qui s'est passé à nantes alors
de la fête de la musique avec la
disparition de steve lors d'une
opération policière
steve est depuis disparu on ne sait pas
où il est ce que vous enquêter sur cette
affaire et est ce que ap ailleurs fait
un reportage est plus dans un article
merveilleux là dessus chez nous on va
les retrouver en plus cela fait elle
dessine non seulement un superbe
reporter cette décision a fait des
dessins très très fort
bah c'est à l'image de ce que je disais
tout à l'heure sur ce mot que le pouvoir
ne veut même pas être entendu prononcer
c'est les violences policières
on a quand même plaisant de la
république dit dans un état droit n'y a
pas de violences policières sur le site
l'état de droit c'est pas qu'il ait pas
de violences policières
mme état de droit c'est que la
république s'occupe des violences
policières et les punisse c'est ça
l'état de droit bien sûr des policiers
peuvent faire commettre des bavures et
mal se comporter et commettre des
violences
je veux dire partir du principe qu'un
policier ne peut pas mettre de violence
enfin c'est un défi à la raison un
journaliste peut faire des bêtises un
policier peut faire débiter 20 ministres
avoir un compte en suisse
c'est pas c'est pas parce que vous avez
effacé un mot vous avez effacé la
réalité que la dernière c'est pourtant
ce qu'ils essayent de faire c'est hyper
inquiétant moi je trouve que la
sémantique c'est c'est sans mauvais jeu
de mots le premier lieu d'un delà de la
symbolique bavarde bavarde de ce qu'il
ya derrière un pouvoir
bah vous rendez compte que là on a quand
même une personne à marseille de 82 ans
qui s'est plaint flash mm red one qui
est mort qui est morte
la situation de l'enquète se passe est
extravagante
les policiers mis en cause ne veulent
pas donner larmes qui attire et qui
permettrait d'identifier quelles erreurs
j'ai plein ne trouve rien à redire
la caméra pas mal marché pas la caméra
donc on peut pas peux pas vous dire
lequel a tiré une personne qui est morte
je sais pas une gilet jaune la vieille
dame elle fermait ses volets elle est
morte
steve à nantes pour répondre à votre
question on est quand même sur de la
fête de la musique on a une charge
policière fait ya eu les images 1 je
crois que c'est un site un peu
activistes si notre révolte notre
révolte et qui a publié certaines images
d'une interview chargée hier vers le
virage menant aux heures du matin hyper
violente au port de la loire à 14
personnes qui tombent malades qui
tombent dans l'eau vers ho heureusement
qu'il y avait des pompiers qui étaient
là et alain qu'on n'a pas retrouvé les
sky ou un mot du ministre de l'intérieur
pour la famille avait entendu ce qu'ils
sont allés sur place ils sont allés sur
place pour aller voir et dire est allé
chez les parents ou le frère ou les amis
là il ya pourquoi n'y a pas d'image de
communication que le mistral faire pour
qu'on n'invite pas les caméras pas parce
qu'ils y vont pas en fait parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de mon pour ça mais pourquoi
on a pas de mots pour quelqu'un qui a
disparu après une charge policière
pourquoi on a pas de mots pour la
vieille dame pourquoi on a on n'a que
des mots pour les policiers et c'est
normal d'avoir des mots pour les
policiers
bien sûr tu es policiers qui sont
victimes de violence est absolument
insupportable et qu'il faut les défendre
mais quand on est à la tête de l'état on
a des mots pour tout le monde on est le
président de tout le monde et ça je
trouve ça mais c'est révoltant faisaient
ces révoltes est donc bon ben on fait
une travail
voilà et dont ceux où est ce steve est
devenu un mantra tragique des réseaux
sociaux est bon à mediapart on nous on
publie depuis le début le travail de
david dufresne avait dufresne qui voyait
très bien puisqu'il était à l'origine de
mediapart qui est un journaliste en
essayant de libération qu'on a fait en
live et qui a interpellé pour ceux qui
connaissent pas à l'eau l'ajoulot place
beauvau son secteur et ça sur twitter et
qui a fait un travail de documentation
exceptionnelle de ce conte de ce que
sont les violences policières et vous
rendez compte
mais c'est orwélien dire qu'on a des
images de policiers qui gaz comme ça des
gamins enfin en tout cas des jeunes par
terre comme on arrosera des tomates on a
des policiers qui tire au flash ball sur
des gens qu'on a une main levée on a les
mains arrachées on a des personnes
éborgné on a des personnes mutilées dans
les visages sont arrachés qui sont pas
tous des gens à qui on reproche d'avoir
attaqué les policières pas du tout et la
patronne de l'igpn la police des polices
elle dit y a pas de violence face aux
images ce que je vous ai dit parfois il
ya des gens pour nous dire que deux et
deux ça fait pas quatre mais bien quand
on dit que deux les deux ça fait pas 4
quand on a perdu une main parce qu'on a
voulu manifester où on a perdu son oeil
je pense que ça rend dingue je pense que
ça rende un lien pays
et là il ya une énorme responsabilité à
part regarder les faits en face
est ce que les emparer et ce pan de
l'histoire de steve à nantes est
absolument sûr que quelque part on bat
la communication de l'état des ministres
c'est quoi pour vous c'est du mépris
c'est je sais pas c'est sauve qui peut
c'est
moi d'abord c'est femme n'a quand même
quelque chose de bizarre dans ce qui est
le maquereau nizon qui est un peu dur à
cerner on sait pas bien quel point ces
vertébrés oussalé pas dans la cabine des
mini je crois que c'est marlène schiappa
qui ai dit si vous aimez la france vous
rejoignez la république en marge
l'at-il vous rejoignez pas la république
engagé table et là la france genre c'est
l'anti france quoi c'est non et les
autres tremper le césarisme un bien
qu'il ya moi et le reste
bon il ya un autre parti qui ressemble
beaucoup à la république en marquant son
côté gazeuses comme on dit dans les
colonnes dans les relais dans les
gazettes
c'est la france insoumise et le premier
qui en parle le mieux c'est monsieur
mélenchon lui même qui a dit je sais
plus et c'est à claude askolovitch qu'il
a dit ça je sais plus c'était dans
vanity fair ou dans l'obs vous retrouver
ça au moment de la campagne
présidentielle ce qui nous revient que
chaque geste monsieur mélenchon avait
dit il ya deux césarisme en france il ya
celui de monsieur macron il ya le mien
et c'est le mien qui va gagner parce que
j'ai une base sociale et populaire bon
n'a pas tout à fait une raison mais peu
importe et mais ce côté de moi et la
foule
il ya plus de corps intermédiaires il ya
plus d'intercesseur n'ya pas de
démocratie interne
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui un peu raconté
par monsieur villani sur la désignation
de monsieur griveaux pour les
municipales à paris 1
c'est voilà c'est secret c'est pas de
démocratie interne et en désign c'est ce
que dénonce en tout cas cédric cédric
villani assassines du père inquiétant en
fait les contre-pouvoirs c'est un peu la
démocratie c'est le conflit c'est la
gestion du conflit de démocratie c'est
pas un bloc monolithique ou dormez
tranquilles braves gens pas ça c'est
pour ça qu'il ya des institutions c'est
pour ça que l'un des pères de la nation
montesquieu a dit que par la disposition
des choses le pouvoir doit arrêter le
pouvoir
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des séparation
des pouvoirs c'est pas pour que les
pouvoirs face qui veulent chacun de leur
côté
c'est pour qu'il puisse entrer en
conflit parce que c'est de ce couple
quenelle équilibres démocratiques
c'est pour ça qu'il ya l'exécutif le
judiciaire
le législatif et que l'un peut contrôler
l'autre 1 et cette façon-là de de
résumer la volonté de tous
l'activisme d'un seul une sorte de
monarque républicain dans la vème
république le président bon bah c'est
pas c'est pas rassurant et donc la com
qui va avec pour répondre à votre
question est une comme qui de plus en
plus fait fi des faits je suis désolé de
l'allitération les a fait fi des faits
bon et les effets de cela et bien c'est
de d'effacer ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure la frontière entre le vrai le
faux
et là je pense qu'on peut collectivement
perdre un peu la raison
comment on se protège en tant que
journaliste justement quand on révèle
autant voilà d'informations sur des
personnes qui peuvent être mais aussi
puissantes quelques parents que ce soit
en politique ou autre comment on évite
les pressions comment on évite la
comment se protège de façon générale
d'abord nous on se met à l'abri des
pressions économiques qui sont parfois
les pieds en journalisme on est à l'abri
des pressions économiques où il ya
personne qui a le moins intérêt sur
mediapart et qui a le moindre levier
pour nous demander de faire ou de ne pas
faire donc on n'est à l'abri de cela ce
soit en termes d'actionnaires ou en
termes de d'annonceurs dans la publicité
premièrement deuxièmement on a cultivé
au sein du journal
peut-être grâce aux apéros la culture de
camaraderie je sais pas comment on peut
appeler ça de bienveillance entre nous
comment dire c'est un journal où on
apprend à se serrer les coudes quoi et à
se tenir chaud et donc bah oui des fois
ça tangue s'attendre quand on révèle ces
informations
et pas un nous on a on a tout un tas
voilà on est on est là et on se tient
chaud et on fait face et puis ensuite on
est prudent on est prudent c'est à dire
que ben oui on fait attention à nos
communications préféré rencontrer les
gens pour de vrai mais c'est par exemple
celle avantage de gagner des sous c'est
pour ça qu'on veut des lecteurs d'un
nouvel électeur à condition qu'ils
soient contents de ce qu'ils lisent de
chez nous évidemment qu'on est contente
mais c'est pour ça que c'est important
d'être rentable pour un journal c'est
qu'on a les moyens de notre obsession
journalistique et on a du temps pour en
perdre un
c'est ça la pour moi la clé de la
réussite journalistique c'est d'avoir du
temps pour en perdre
on n'a pas un rapport unique
utilitariste à toulon rendez vous on
peut prendre l'avion pour aller à
l'autre bout du monde rencontrer des
gens il revenir en dix ans pour
l'instant je ne vais rien faire et c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui arrive moi je peux
en témoigner les gens du journal peuvent
en témoigner
voilà et d'impôts faire ça faut des
moyens c'est pas pour on va manger du
homard ou boire du mouton rothschild
2004 à 600 euros la bouteille
mais c'est pour faire notre travail géré
de l'information ça coûte de l'argent
d'un symbole de l'argent et puis parfois
c'est ben c'est ça c'est un truc de
douches écossaises journalisme pense
qu'on va y arriver si on n'arrive pas
c'est chaud c'est froid on y arrive en
fait non puis au bout de six mois ça
m'arrache en fait il ya un déclic etc
voilà c'est de cela que n'est en fait
les
les enquêtes et donc c'est tout cela
qu'on essaye de défendre à mediapart et
c'est comme ça qu'on se protège de des
attaques des mises en cause ou des
protections ou des dés de l'extérieur
qui peuvent arriver parce qu'on dérange
tel ou tel pouvoir que ce soit sous la
gauche ou la droite face à l'extrême
gauche à l'extrême droite peu importe je
dis ça et ça n'empêche pas un journal
d'avoir des valeurs de défendre des
convictions le mediapart sur des
convictions et plutôt un journal
j'aimais bien le terme est maintenant il
a été captée par emmanuel macron mais
progressiste jeu vous donnera de gauche
ben progressiste on est plus
progressiste le conservateur voilà bah
oui bien sûr mais ça veut pas dire que
l'on ferme les yeux sur les
représentants politiques du progressisme
en france le dire on a fait des
révélations sont tous les partis
politiques
tu mens tous bons donc voilà on est
juste on fait notre métier dans les
commentaires et pourquoi personne ne
parle de julian assange
voilà on déplorant pour certains le fait
qu'il aura peut-être pas été assez des
shows du nu protéger ou d'autres pas
forcément mediapart mais de façon
générale je trouve que c'est qu'en fait
je reçois passion dans la question de
julian assange parce que il ya la
question des principes et là qu'il ya la
question des personnages du personnage
et que parfois on peut faire la part des
choses entre les principes et le
personnage c'est à dire que l'attak
l'insigne d'attac judiciaire dont il est
la victime par les états unis qui
consiste à criminaliser un travail
journalistique en le qualifiant d'
espionnage
c'est scandaleux et donc par principe il
faut évidemment défendre ce que ce café
julien assange
pour autant est ce que tout ce qu'elle
fait julian assange méritent d'être
défendus en tout cas par un journal
comme médiapart banon il ya certains
certaines prises de position ses
rapports qu'il a pu avoir avec la russie
de monsieur poutine qui est tout tourne
soif un amoureux des libertés 1 le
rapport muller de robert müller de l'
enquête sur l'ingérence russes citent à
de très nombreuses reprises
wikileaks avec des éléments quand même
qu'on crée un lié à monsieur poutine et
à monsieur trump bon ben voilà on a le
droit aussi de regarder ça calmement
ça veut pas dire que il faut jeter toute
l'histoire du julian assange et de
wikileaks avec avec l'eau du bain
pas du tout mais on peut faire la part
des choses on peut dire d'un côté l'
attaque judiciaire qui est une attaque
contre la liberté d'informer en
qualifiant le journalisme d'espionnage
n'est pas acceptable
on peut aussi avoir un regard critique
sur sa position entre position
d'intérêts entre monsieur poutine
par exemple sur la sphère de rugy a
calmement on se dit passé j'ai assez
d'éléments pour publier ce que vous
attendez d'avoir ficelé toutes les
enquêtes où tous les éléments autour du
goût en fils et moi l'élément
déclencheur de se dire voilà par exemple
l'ancien crossman gratton a quand on a
les photos sur les dîners qu'on ait en
identifier qu'on a lu les participants
qu'on a des cartons de visite qu'on a eu
des sources que ce soit au sein de
l'assemblée ou dans les entourages conte
à respecter le contradictoire avec et
monsieur burgy le cabinet du ministre et
madame du rgi qu'entre le sujet et mur
quand le fruit est mûr pour lequel est
d'ailleurs j'avais posé les questions en
même temps dès lundi dernier et là
monsieur d'origine et sur les dîners et
sur les travaux sur les dîners on a eu
une première réponse en fait il perd
embarrassé de monsieur de logique était
assez simple à intégrer à notre travail
on a fait le premier papier et on a
attendu pour les travaux pour une raison
simple c'est qu'ils nous ont abreuvés
document une autre stratégie fait c'est
de t'envoyer plein de trucs aux
journalistes dont ils ont abreuvé de
documents de mails etc et donc il a
fallu pour nous tous dépiauter tout
vérifié dans ce qui nous envoyait et
donc le temps de faire ce tout ça a pris
48 heures on a fait le deuxième papier
le deuxième papier ensuite donc vraiment
c'est comme un fruit
voilà un papier c'est un set un fruit
mûr qu'on public quand il est mûr est ce
que du coup quand vous avez commencé à
publier ces informations ça en appeler
d'autres
c'est considère que la par exemple à
partie au moment où c'est oublier ces
informations il ya d'autres éléments qui
viennent à chaque fois que mediapart
fait des révélations
il ya un effet évidemment de loupe sur
le journal parce qu'on parle d'eux
dans les télés radios sur prévue et
touchera et donc il ya forcément des
gens qu'ils abusent ils ont l'air
indépendants ils défendent leurs infos
mot peut-être qu'ils vont réussir à
faire sortir ce que j'essaye donc on est
submergé d'informations mais on préfère
en avoir trop que pas assez
et y compris sur un sujet particulier et
je dois dire que le jeune d'exemples de
rugy est assez caricatural c'est à dire
que je crois que la défense dont tout le
monde comprend à quel point les
claudicante un brin des balantes de
monsieur d'origine
oui ça suscite beaucoup d'indignation
auprès de gens mais auprès de gens qui
ont des informations et c'est assez
intéressant dont on est abreuvé on est
abreuvé de choses sans intérêt et puis
on est abreuvé le parfois pas abreuvés
monsois des choses hyper intéressante
on verra si on aura droit elle est
publiée jeudi
on verra je peux pas de nouveaux
éléments qui pourraient arriver mais
cela par exemple sur le l'enquète que
vous m'ayez depuis maintenant quelques
semaines quelques mois
est-ce qu'il ya déjà des éléments de
nouveaux articles de nouvelles
révélations qui sont prêtes à être
publiées dans les biberons remplis choix
je reste très prudent avec tout ça parce
que vraiment on répond de ce qu'on a
écrit parce qu'on va je fais aucune
prophétie oui et ce qu'on a des fils à
tirer ce qu'on a des pistes superbe
oui absolument voilà mais on en parlera
qu'on se sera publié d'abord pour une
raison très simple j'aime d'abord c'est
un au lecteur d'en avoir la primeur
ils s'abonnent à médiapart pour ça et
c'est bien normal
et voilà et donc il peut arriver
tellement de choses avant la publication
d'un article qui peut faire que bah
finalement on n'est plus très sûr mais
potentiellement de nouveaux éléments sur
mediapart sur la sphère de rugy
potentiellement la redéfinition 15 films
en tout cas un grand merci fabrice arfi
d'avoir répondu à mes questions aussi ça
les internautes en aussi on essaie d'en
prendre quelques unes on n'aurait que je
dis souvent on aurait pu faire des
heures de live
je sais que vous faites aussi des elfes
et où il ya des tas de questions donc
vous voyez bien l'idée c'est énormément
de questions et essayer de prendre au
delà des questions que j'ai pu citer
mais aussi prendre des certaine
sensibilité comme celle de julian
assange ou d'autres qui ont plusieurs
dans ce live notamment sur la question
des journalistes parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de questions
on est énormément moi même temps j'en
lis énormément interpellé aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux en place par s'en lasser
le travail etc embêter tout le monde
dans notre métier et pas à devoir rendre
des comptes tout expliquer comment mais
notre métier c'est normal
et justement c'était intéressant pouvoir
y répondre on s'excuse et d autres
questions qu'on n'a pas pu prendre
forcément ce sera peut-être l'occasion
de le faire prochainement à l'occasion
je dis ça pour ceux qui viennent de nous
rejoindre sur le live que l'ensemble de
ce direct va être disponible dans
quelques instants
on revient donc en long et en large sur
la sphère de rugy sur les révélations
vous avez fait mais aussi en réponse
parce que c'est vrai que françois de
rugy sur ces réseaux sociaux a apporté
des éléments et surtout ce matin au
micro de jean jacques bourdin sur rmc à
voile a essayé de répondre à certains
revenus en fait il fait exactement ce
que cahuzac l'avait fait qu'il veut
transformer la sphère mano à mano
entre un ministre et un journal fait il
veut isoler médiapart c'est le faire il
va faire un match de boxe avec mediapart
mais nous ce n'est pas le problème de
bougie pour les minots jc des
informations confuses
c'est médiapart et c'est ce qu'il veut
faire c'est de la com c'est un combat
d'irak csii victime qu'il veut il veut
faire c'est ce qu'est exactement ce
qu'ils avaient fait cahuzac c'est à dire
2 c'est une façon de circonscrire un
incendie en fait c'est de limiter le
combat à un homme fasse un journal et
d'alimenter l'idée qu'en fait le journal
en veut à l'homme et que si on fait ça
c'est pas pour le journalisme c'est
parce qu on en a contre lui
y'a rien de plus faux mais c'est à des
stratégies de communication qui peuvent
porter auprès des militants voilà donc
durant ce live on n'a rien voilà vous
avez pu répondre à chacun de ses
arguments que ce soit en réponse à vos
informations et aussi vers différentes
attaques de vue que c'est vrai qu'à
plusieurs reprises il a pu vous cibler
directement
donc voilà c'est à voir ou revoir tout
de suite je vous remercie il ya beaucoup
de commentaires très sympathique pour le
live envers vous envers nous donc c'est
très bien merci à vous et puis on se
retrouve très très vite sur bruit pour
de nouvelles images en direct
bien sûr sur mediapart pour continue de
suivre l'actualité de façon générale et
peut-être d'autres d'auto de sa
formation sur de rugy à voir et puis
aussi à nous suivre sur brut pour de
nouvelles voilà deux nouvelles vidéos
qui ont rejoint la journée et nouveau
direct à tout moment quand l'actualité
l'exigent comme c'était le cas hier soir
on était sur les champs-elysées au
moment où donc algériens et tunisiens
sont retrouvés pour fêter leur victoire
en coupe d'afrique des nations 1 live en
deux temps que c'était un peu plus
festif au début un peu moins en seconde
partie de soirée trois heures de live
qui vous permettent de voir ce qui s'est
passé le mieux comprendre c'est à revoir
dans notre fil d'actualité donc
n'hésitez pas à nous suivre
et puis on se retrouve très très vite
sur brut pour de nouvelles images en
direct c'est vendredi donc bonnes
vacances à ceux qui seront en vacances
et puis très bon début de week-end à
ceux qui vont l'être dans quelques
heures on se retrouve très très vite
merci encore fabrice arfi et bonne
journée à tous 6